the lush tropical paradise the clothes
the faces everything has turned brown
and gray every day hope you've Adam digs
deeper into the ground in search of tin
one of the most sought after of precious
metals now that's used in every mobile
phone you might say we risk our lives so
others can use their telephones it
happens all the time the hill caves in
on you and you're buried alive
prospecting for tin is fairly dangerous
Vanka off the coast of Sumatra is a
Treasure Island buried in its soil is
more tin per cubic meter than anywhere
else on earth
tin has made the island rich and
brutally destroyed it banker has become
a vast no-man's land its landscape a sea
of craters most of the tin mining is
illegal
the island is riddled with thousands of
improvised mines
the earth is sucked up through big hoses
and washed until nothing remains but the
precious black metal hole families live
from mining housewives young men the
elderly teenagers even children cynthia
is just 12
I come here all the time after school
working in the mine is fun the big
manufacturers of mobile phones tablets
and other devices make no secret of the
fact that they draw tin from vodka but
with child labor some companies have
promised changes but actions rarely
follow such words the Friends of the
Earth environmental organization has
been campaigning for years to force the
companies to take more responsibility
we've appealed to the major electronics
concerns over and over to take some
action to stop the destruction of nature
but we're not seeing any progress the
companies aren't living up to their
responsibilities added to the
environmental damage and child labor is
the health hazard to everyone involved
in tin mining minor buzzer E has been
confined to his mattress for three weeks
almost paralyzed with pain he broke two
ribs and his pubic bone maybe even a hip
I can hardly remember the accident I was
working down in the mine when the entire
Hill fell on me mat dual the state would
pay for buzzer EES operation but he's
afraid of the doctors and the hospital
he trusts the medicine men from his
village their hurdle tinctures are
supposed to heal his broken bones would
you say the accident could have been
prevented
got occupy decides I suppose so we could
have terraced the sides of the pit that
would have made the whole slope more
stable but it would have taken time and
time is money
I keep that night Roma
Wildcat miners keep opening new pits
they're active off bunkers coast as well
offshore mining is illegal within six
kilometers of the coast but just two
kilometers out is a floating village the
makeshift rafts are lashed together
patched up and kept afloat with
improvised prepares the generators send
a deafening roar and clouds of diesel
exhaust across the water it's hell on
waves the man in the tattered wetsuit is
Harry Ono like almost everyone here he
used to be a fisherman but the tin boom
has all but destroyed his traditional
livelihood my family is afraid for me
but I have to do this job or we wouldn't
be able to survive
sometimes a look can speak volumes at
least one casualty is certain the sea
itself the water is brown from all the
sediment churned up here to the divers
use giant hoses to suck up the seabed
and everything on it fish crabs and
coral the marine environment is slowly
dying pieces of it come out on the raft
above in the form of a brown sludge that
has to be washed away to expose the
precious tin
if we don't find anything right away we
go a little farther or just dig deeper
there will always be time for us to mine
but the tin ore deposits are not endless
eventually they'll be exhausted the
authorities warn and what will the
people here do them tourists are not
likely to turn up in this wasteland of
Rock and craters any time soon
every attempt at reforestation has so
far failed the soil is leached and the
rivers poisoned with toxic chemicals
even bankers few conservation areas have
been mercilessly stripped of tin ore for
the sake of a few rupiah in the evening
the sacks full of the heavy metal
assaulted the traders this mine owner is
satisfied for the day's yield her
workers have extracted nearly 200 kilos
in the last few days
the ship's leave bunker loaded with Tim
leaving behind a devastated island every
day its people help destroy a little
more of their home their forests and sea
life and for anyone who's ever been to
bunker the sense of joy at buying a new
mobile phone may be ruined as well